I think they need to have heroes that
inspire them I think they need to see
the adults in the generation above them
well two things they need to see the
adults in the generation above them as
people who are living lives of integrity
people who are living passionately
people who are living beyond themselves
who are not satisfied with trite answers
people who are willing to go there to
enter into any discussion no topic is
off-limits and they see people who
actually put their faith into practice
it seems like maybe students or younger
generation see their parents generation
as those who did a lot of talking but
not a lot of action so I think they need
to see that happening to inspire them
but I also think that they need to
believe that they have something
significant to contribute there's been a
lot of talk in the last I don't know 15
to 20 years about the generations I'm a
baby boomer so the generations coming
behind me it's been a lot of criticism
of them as being people very
self-absorbed thinking about the career
thinking about where they're going to go
in life materialistic and I think if
they can see themselves as somebody who
can make a significant contribution that
really all of these things that we're
dealing with on a world basis all the
things that you're even bringing up that
if they don't see themselves as is not
only part of the solution but the
solution I think when they get mobilized
to that then then they'll get active
last week on world aids day we did not
only a global summit on aids for just
anybody who wanted to come bet on world
aids day we did a youth summit and we
had about a thousand students junior
high to college students gathered at our
church plus two hundred churches who
simulcast it so there were several more
thousand who are watching by simulcast
there were like four thousand students
on World AIDS Day who were gathered in
one place saying you know what we're
going to take on HIV we're not content
to let this be something that only our
parents generation dealt with we're not
content to just let this be something
that takes over and continues to
decimate lives we're taking a stand
we're committing to remain HIV free
ourselves we're committed to helping
other students remain a chai free and
we're going to care for people who are
HIV positive the excitement in that
place was probably you could touch it
you could cut it with a knife they went
out of there so jazzed and so
enthusiastic believing that they had a
contribution to make to a significant
world problem